[Music]
of course until everyone are gonna
settle in uh let's start with a few
questions it's always fun so with a
raise of hand how many people are using
Jupiter notebooks yeah okay you're here
in this session obviously
on those Jupiter notebooks how many of
you are collaborating with other people
on the same project
KMS
same Notebook on the same project
and how many of you are doing it to
deploy that model that you're building
to production
yeah
building in the notebook okay yeah very
very little there was uh what I imagined
um cool so Jupiter notebooks uh born out
of the IPython back in 2014 they've
become the de facto standard tool for
data scientists to build their projects
to give you the sense of its impact
Jupiter notebooks was awarded the 2017
ACM award which is the prestige award
shared with Java Unix and the web
however using it to build ammo project
and application for production has
introduced challenges that we have never
encountered before the new and undefined
format structure and workflow revealed
blind spots that made its usage in
production environment and uphill battle
um and in our session today we're going
to discuss about seven best practices
that will help us reduce or shorten the
time between our research tape to moving
to production and we're going to use
envelops tools and techniques
so a few words about me I'm near
barazida thank you all for joining the
session today
thank you uh I paid him to do that my
background combines a structural
analysis computer vision engineering and
envelopes research I'm leading the
envelopes and Outreach team at dagsub so
shout out to all the dags up team that
are here which is basically the GitHub
for ML and my team is researching and
implementing mlop Solutions and
workflows for collaborative ML and in
this session wait one click
and another click awesome and basically
in this session today I aim to bring you
the essence of what we've learned about
using jupyter notebooks when building
machine learning models in production
environment
and so far the hypothesis that had the
highest statistical significant was that
the hypothesis that had the highest
statistical significant is that when the
best way to get data scientist attention
is by using three words
envelopes notebooks and production and
today today we're going to have them all
so I'd like to start with the Dark Side
of notebooks and from there move to
towards delight and hopefully this slide
is not going to be a heavy train that is
headed our way
and talking about the bad side of or the
Dark Side Of Jupiter notebooks with
notebooks we can run out of order cells
edit them after we already ran them once
and this is a huge disadvantage for
reproducibility and it makes us to put
we need to put a lot of effort into
tracking the kernel State when executing
it also behind the scenes jupyter
notebooks are basically a very large
Json file which makes it very hard to
diff and track or version with Git
unless the code hosted in the jupyter
notebooks can't be called outside the
notebook making it very hard to test and
to reuse our code in other projects so
why are we using jupyter notebooks that
just throw them out of the window and go
back to the good old-fashioned IDE
well jupyter notebooks basically gives
us some superhuman abilities and are
after all a very good tool they give us
an interactive way to work with our code
they have built-in visualizations that
makes that we can see the results of our
code the result of our code next to the
cell that already ran it and this is
very good for communicating our work to
other colleagues and to not so technical
stakeholders and basically jupyter
notebooks are great for quick
prototyping so our sandbox environment
and now that we understand that jupyter
notebooks are good but also have their
dark side how can we utilize them and
make the use of them more productive
when we are in a production environment
So based on our research we found that
by using seven best practices it will
make the research time or the
productionizing time uh shorter the
first is host our code in modules which
basically means take all the code that
we are hosting in the notebook to python
modules that doesn't relay on any Global
variable and take everything in its
argument and then import it back you're
going to see how it uh we're going to
see it in just a minute we'd like to
version everything so our code our data
our models our experiments basically
everything we want to have peer reviews
of someone that is reviewing our work we
want to track our experiments we want to
use task oriented notebooks so note this
spaghetti notebook that has thousands of
cells so we want to break it based on
the test that we're using it for we want
to track our environment setting and
let's use scripts for training and
deployment
and to make this seven best practices
more practical let's take a common
scenario and in our scenario our team
lead just got off the phone with the CEO
and there is a new project in the funnel
Save the Planet surprisingly the CEO
wants it in production by end of week
because it's a freaking Game Changer so
what are you going to do now huh you're
going to roll up your sleeves you're
going to put on your headset you're
going to find the perfect gem for this
task you're going to open a new desktop
and you're gonna run to get some coffee
no I'm kidding you're probably going to
download the no the data set to your
local machine you're going to fire a
jupyter notebook and you're going to
start exploring the data at hand
but hold your horses Cowboys this is not
your first rodeo you over you already
created a one of a kind never heard of
data plots and Analysis but where are
they so you're gonna probably start
firing up old Jupiter notebooks cross
through dozens of sales and output
looking through hundreds of code lines
just to find that one function that does
what you intended to do but although
witnessing the outstanding work and I'm
sure that you're doing outstanding work
that you did a few months back it's
highly time consuming and what we want
is an easy way to search for the pieces
of code that we need and import it back
or we use it in our project and this
among other good reasons we want to move
our code to python modules and what do I
mean by that so once we got our initial
piece of code to do what it was intended
to do so in this case we had an amazing
plot of global warming distribution what
we want to do we want to take this piece
of code
two a python script put it in a a
function that doesn't rely on any Global
variable and takes everything as
argument
and then we want to import that function
back to our jupyter notebook and
provided the relevant variables and by
doing that we will first and foremost be
able to use uh learn so static code
analysis to flag programming errors and
for me it's basically like testing but
it takes us to the next point which is
we'll be able to run unitest on our code
making it uh better and so we won't fail
in production and last we're going to
stay dry and in the Israeli winter with
that it's very rainy not uh we won't
repeat ourselves so we will be able to
reuse our code in the same project or in
other project very easily because it's
basically importing a function from a
python module can also be r or Julia but
this is by data so I'm not going to
mention other languages
um cool so now that we can move faster
without breaking anything uh sorry Mark
Zuckerberg for uh ruining your
hypothesis we can start exploring our
data but what should we do when we gonna
reach a good result or a dead end should
we just take the piece of code copy it
and paste it at the bottom of the
notebook or maybe Stone Age version or
notebook so just like copy and paste The
Notebook give it like a unique name Eda
from December 2022 and then go back to
it when we want it but only if there was
the magical tool that enables Version
Control and going back in time with code
oh right we have git for it so yeah I
had to click so this is a very cool meme
um so with Git we can work in isolated
environment we can recover work we can
use CI CD Automation and the list just
goes on and on git is very very good for
Version Control and for managing
project that has code but remember this
is not a software development project
this is a machine learning project
uh the other than our code files and our
notebooks in this case we also have
other components such as models such as
data such as pipelines
Etc and in most cases those components
are going to be the focal point of our
experiments when we'd like to reproduce
them so because of that what we want to
do we want to version everything and for
data versioning or for large file
versioning a lot of tools emerge in
recent years that provide very good
solutions for specific uh tasks so some
provide better solution for unstructured
data the other for tabular data and the
list just goes on and on yeah you can
take pictures
um don't forget to add mention
um so basically there's a tons of very
good open source tools out there and
some not open source that helps us to
version uh our large files some are good
for specific use cases so what I
recommend in this case research for the
tool that fits your needs before using
it or injecting it into your pipeline
and by versioning everything we'll be
able to avoid ad hoc versioning so no
more copying pasting or Stone Age
versioning we'll be able to share our
large files easily so it can be a git
commit or a version of your data very
easily within the team and we're also
going to be able to reproduce our
results because we know which data set
was used to train our model and then we
version also our model so all we need to
do is go back to that experiment and we
have everything that was used in that
experiment
and
so we broke down explored and tested our
data to create the Mona Lisa of reports
really it's a thing of beauty and now we
feel comfortable comfortable enough to
start processing our data but what if we
missed something what if there's a
hidden bias in our work or our
hypothesis is not very it's not truly
supported by the data at hand so what we
want to do we want to we want our work
to be passed under the magnifying vest
of our colleagues an important step that
as data scientists we sometimes neglect
or or not doing because it's very hard
to do how can someone review our
notebook how can we communicate over our
notebook can we diff notebooks so in
this case what we're using under the
hood at dags up for Notebook this thing
is nbdime on top of that we added the
the ability to also comment on Notebook
cells there's a lot of add-ons such as
also review and B that I know this is
the extension that GitHub uses so
there's a lot of tools and extension to
our jupyter notebooks out there that
will enable code review but this is
something that we shouldn't Miss because
think of it this is connected to a
software development project no one is
going to deploy anything to production
without having peer review so the same
in data science or machine learning
projects and by doing that we're going
to reduce the bias in our work and we'll
be able to find bugs earlier in the
stage in a earlier stage before
deploying to production or when reaching
to the point where we want to deploy to
production
cool so we're three days into the
project and haven't run a single cell
that contains fit
we want to train a model and we want it
now
but just before we do that keep in mind
that we're conducting a research here
this is not a software development
project and exploring or hypothesizing
without keeping track of the experiments
is basically meaningless we need to keep
track of everything that we're doing and
the same as with large file versioning a
lot of tools emerge in recent years for
experiment tracking and in this case I
believe that it doesn't really matter
with which Hammer you choose to hit the
nail as long as you punch it through so
we have weights and biases ammo flow
comment ML and many more and by doing
that by also tracking our experiment in
the sense where if I'm going to conduct
an experiment and let's say Omer is
going to conduct an experiment we're
going to lock the same hype base hyper
parameters and the same metrics and then
we'll be able to
no this is Omer uh so we'll be able to
compare apples to apples so we have the
same metrics and the same hyper
parameters and we'll be we will be able
to choose the best experiment and then
either double down on so let's say hyper
parameter tuning for it or then deploy
it to production
and by doing that we're going to build a
knowledge base for our project as we go
because we're keeping track of
everything that we're doing we'll be
able to reproduce our the experiment to
some extent because we're keeping track
of the hyper parameters so we'll be able
to rerun the training and also we're
going to avoid ad hoc recording that
currently a lot of people are doing in a
spreadsheet or whatnot and in this case
we're keeping track of the same hyper
parameters the same metrics the same
artifacts and we can compare between
works of different uh team members
awesome so the design is closing in and
you find yourself going back and forth
between data processing and modeling
data processing and modeling and you
start fitting the heat from your boss to
the point where she decides to add two
new team members to the project but what
now okay so Omer you're going to take
cells 1 to 29 uh let's say NOAA is going
to take sales 30 to 60 and I'm going to
take cell 16 above but Noah keep in mind
that cell number 36 it takes forever to
run it so just don't rerun it again well
this is not a way to collaborate with
other people on a project so what we
want here we want to use designated uh
notebooks for designated tasks so a
notebook pair test so let's say we have
a data processing test so we'll have a
designated notebook for data processing
we have a modeling test so we're going
to have a designated notebook for
building our model and so on and so on
and this way when we uh when we're going
to scale the number of team members uh
on the same project we'll be able to do
it efficiently also it's going to be
much more easier to maintain review and
debug our work unless we can have a
clear structure to our project meaning
we know that the data processing step
needs to take an input the raw data and
it outputs a processed data and then the
modeling step no we know which type of
or how it needs to receive the process
data so this is its input and then what
it's going to Output it's a trained
model so we have a clear structure clear
dag as in dagsub to to our project and
this way we have a clear structure it's
also helped for onboarding but very much
for maintaining
okay so we're six hours before the
deadline and we have one less training
that we need to run but the person in
charge of modeling just called in sick I
just wish this week would be over with
so what you're gonna do you're gonna
probably connect to your favorite cloud
provider and there is no such thing
you're going to fire a monster machine
you're going to pull the entire uh
project with the latest version of your
notebook and you're gonna run hit all
sales so cross your fingers that is
going to work and run
error retrieving driver version kernel
reported driver version not implemented
we're getting errors because our version
of tensorflow doesn't support the driver
ah I just wish this week would be over
with so in this sense notebook should be
reproducible to the extensor anyone on
the team can uh take the notebook from
it we left it and re-run it easily by
and like put it give it the same input
and get the same output and in this case
what I'm trying to say here that we
should track all of our dependencies in
our project so the base case is going to
be
requirements.txt but taking it to the
next level we also want to keep track of
os level dependencies so which Hardware
we're using uh if we're using GPU which
type of GPU which uh uh codiverse Cuda
version if it connects to the tensorflow
that we're using and we want to
encapsulate everything I would say
dockerize everything
so we will be able to rerun The Notebook
easily and by doing that we'll be able
to reproduce our result easily so
reproducibility it's important thing in
machine learning we'll be able to either
rate over our work easily and we can
also have a proper handoff between the
ammo team and the mlops team that
eventually needs to deploy the model to
production
Okay so we've explored process version
build train and pickled our model this
is the time to push the deployment
button and we are ready to do so so what
we're going to do we're going to
probably send our notebook to the
envelops team and ask them to deploy it
as an endpoint to production
please don't do that
yeah this is the meme okay
so don't deploy your models to
production there are so many reason why
not to use our model our notebooks in
production so first and foremost there
are no like there's a lot of uh very uh
commonly used or well-established CI CD
tools that are not supporting Jupiter
notebooks and to use them so they don't
have it out of the box so to use them
you're gonna probably have to do a lot
of hacking in the way also most of the
deployment tools require a lot of
cleaning up and packaging of our
notebook which will probably get to the
point where the notebook is probably
going to be treated or handed as a
python script so why go through all this
Hassle and I think
and also uh or the mo the other thing is
that notebooks are not such a good team
player in production so we're probably
going to use other tools in production
that don't know how to handle with the
format that underlies Jupiter notebooks
which is basically a large Json
and this leads us to the last principle
which is we want to use scripts for
training and deployment and by doing
that it will be much more easier to
maintain our project and also debug if
we have something in production if you
have a bug in production and it will
reduce the downtime
also scripts are more scalable than
Jupiter notebooks and I feel like the
last thing which is the magical part is
that if you're gonna use all the last
six best practices it's going to make
the process of moving to production as
easy as in as approving a pull request
so we can move much more faster to
deploying our model to production
okay so this brings us to the end of
this session so we discussed today how
to make our workflow when using jupyter
notebooks in a production environment
more producible scalable and will help
us move much more faster so a quick
recap will be that first we want to host
all of our code outside the Jupiter
notebooks you want to host them in
modules and then import them back to our
notebooks we want to version everything
so our code our notebooks our data our
models Etc we want to have peer reviews
uh in early stage as early as it can be
of the in the pipeline of the building
or building our model we want to track
our experiment we want to use task
oriented notebooks or break down the
spaghetti notebook into different tests
that we're building
we want to track our environment setting
and our OS level dependencies and last
you want to use scripts for training and
deploying our notebook so with that I
want to thank you all for joining me
today uh it was very fun seeing you here
and having an in-person event thank you
all for that also for the pi data
organizers so urigal Dean everyone all
the team
um and I would love to connect with
everyone here so basically what I'm
doing at dagsub is talking with
technical people that are building ammo
projects listening to their challenges
and what they're facing when trying to
build models to production so I'd love
to chat with you so you can DM me on
LinkedIn or Twitter and I'd love to hear
what are the challenges that you're
facing uh and how are you overcoming
them or if you can overcome them and
maybe there is a solution out there for
you so with that thank you very much and
have a enjoy the rest of your day
any questions
I did I did not understand what are you
at what step you're stopping working
with the notebooks and you start doing
walking with skips are you working
without books only for like prototyping
okay so the gift is going to drive you
crazy so let's go back just to the
beginning
so in the very beginning of our workflow
and this is the first principle and I
think like I know conceptually changing
workflow is very hard so this is the
step that I would recommend generally to
start from what we want to do we want to
take the code that we're hosting in the
notebook export it into python module
and then import it back that without any
dependency of what's going on in The
Notebook and so this is going to lead
you into like having a notebook with
only fun with only with functions that
is going to work as a pipeline okay and
this way you will be able to utilize the
plots that or the interactive the the
interactivity of the jupyter notebook
but once you want to move to the
training basically what you need to do
is take the pipeline that you have in
your notebook copy it to some main
function main script and then run the
main script so basically it's part of
the process you start by exporting the
code to python module then import it
back and once you want to train or
deploy you basically take in the content
of your notebook and transition it into
the relevant script so it can be a
training script it can be a main script
it can be a processing script
Etc and this way you can also build a
dag to your project that interacts with
all the other components and you can
reproduce the entire pipeline from
scratch
did it answer your question uh yeah yeah
it did awesome can I get another
question yeah okay we're gonna charge
the double no problem we have the money
um at the start of the of the
presentation of the
slides yes I heard about Netflix using
uh notebooks in production okay can you
uh level right please
so basically the reason I'm using this
meme is because
Netflix basically build an entire
orchestration around deploying their
models to production and probably 99.9
of cases you are not Netflix so you
don't have the mlops team or the men
slash woman power to build such an
orchestration so it's going to be very
hard for you to build such a thing it's
I can refer you to two blog posts that
were written by Netflix where they
described the architecture but I mainly
not focused on how to do so because in
most cases it's going to be very hard
for companies to do it uh but I will
reference it in the I don't know where
we have a stack or something will we no
nothing okay I'll ping you on whatever
on LinkedIn thank you ping me
okay enough of it
as you said in the beginning versioning
notebooks is like nightmare so you have
like do you know of any tools that
like help you do it better or easier so
I'm gonna split my answer to two first
and foremost jupyter notebooks can
become very heavy because there's a lot
of plots there and then versioning with
Git it becomes very heavy for git to
version and this is where we can utilize
those uh data versioning tool to also
version our notebooks because they can
handle large files and they're gonna
host it in a remote storage so this is
for the versioning and for different
communicating and stuff like that so
there's a lot of add-ons like nbdime
review and B and stuff like that at
dagsub so I'm I hate to talk about dags
up when I'm speaking but basically what
we enable to users is basically to push
their notebooks to your repo then you
can diff sales there communicate over
cells uh and also they can be in your
bucket or in your git server so it
doesn't matter which tool you're
versioning them
but if you're are not using the exub and
using other tools then you can there's a
lot of Open Source or add-ons that you
can use for versioning not for
versioning but for diffing communicating
over notebooks also there are some for
linting and for debugging but it's like
researching for the one that fits your
needs or the the pain that you have and
use it
thank you sure
okay thank you Neil
[Applause]
foreign